Here's something that kind of surprises
many people when they learn SQL.
So far whenever you've done a select.
You've selected from either a table or
a few joined tables.
There's another thing you
can select from as well.
Namely the results of a select query.
This is one form of something called
a subquery or sometimes a subselect.
Remember back in lesson one when I
mentioned that the result of a query
is always a table?
This is why.
Since the result of a query is a table
you can select from it, join it,
aggregate it, and so on.
Here's a table that lists mooseball
players and what team they're on and
the number of points they
scored in the last season.
And here's a query that will find
the highest scoring player's score for
each team.
This uses the max aggregation, grouping
by team, to find the highest score.
But suppose that we want to know
what the average score of a highest
scorer is.
To do this we can take this whole query
and stick it inside of another query.
The outside query, gives the average
of the inside query's results.
The syntax of SQL requires that we give
the subquery result table a name, maxes
here, even though we don't actually
use that word anyplace in the query.
It's just required.